et c'est précisément pour lutter contre
ce genre d'excès qu en italie une petite
ville au sud de florence en toscane a
choisi la démarche inverse pour
préserver un certain art de vivre
le maire a lancé comme un défi à un mot
d'ordre slow food
par opposition précisément à fast food
c'était il ya dix ans aujourd'hui
cette démarche porte ses fruits la ville
n'a jamais été aussi riche et cette
politique fait des émules
reportage gilles rabin et dominique
merlin prendre le temps de vivre de
flâner de goûter le parfum de l'air de
travail et d'écouté de rêver d mais
parce que cet art de vivre se perdre et
que sa petite ville se transformer en
banlieue de florence
le maire de grève et une cliente qui a
dit non et refuser en bloc toute
nouvelle construction
il y a des limites physiques des limites
de route des limites de services d'eau
potable et si nous voulons maintenir un
niveau minimum de qualité de vie et de
bien-être pour les habitants nous devons
dire stop à cette évolution avec lui
tous les villageois ont dit stop
depuis qu rêver une cantine c'est
l'histoire d'un succès exemple stefano
charcutier de père en fils depuis trois
siècles
parce qu'il ne proposait que des
produits locaux fait l'ancienne alors
que les autres vendait de la viande
importée moins cher il a failli fermer
dans les années 80 ont serré les dents
ou ne gagnait pas d'argent tu es tout le
monde nous faisait concurrence y est
c'est notre chance
car aujourd'hui ils ont tous fermé
autignac et nous nous sommes ouverts et
nous viennent ouvert et réactiver ce
qu'ils vont ils le fabrique lui-même ou
comme pour ce fromage sa famille connaît
depuis plusieurs générations
les familles qui le produit
c'est la base du mouvement slow food
lancé ici en réaction au fast-food
savoir ce qu'on fabrique savoir ce qu'on
veut pour que les clients sachent ce
qu'ils mangent nos routes desservant
nommé slow food s'asseoir à table
tranquillement goûter les plats cuisinés
lentement soigneusement mais comme on le
faisait dans la cuisine traditionnelle
du tian dit respecter la nature
encourager des productions locales
préserver l'héritage architectural
mettre les techniques modernes au
service de l'homme c'est une véritable
charte qui a été constituée et ça
rapporte du chômage ici il y en a plein
les jeunes ne quitte plus la ville est
il à la salle ici fondent leurs fans à
40 villes plus importantes suivent le
mouvement comme pas d'où vous ici
orvieto
le maire a construit sous la colline un
réseau de tapis roulant qui amène les
visiteurs au coeur de la cité ce qui a
permis d'interdire à la circulation le
centre historique
louis mercato sur quatre guides nous
avons cherché à rester une ville d'à
nous avons cherché à rester une ville
confortable et garder la grave agréable
comme vous dites mais sans devenir une
réserve d'indiens cette philosophie de
vie et vécu sur ses terres toscane comme
un retour à l'éthique de l'époque de la
renaissance qui est né ici